former prime minister Imran Khan will be
allowed to hold a rally authorities have
ruled the decision comes after his party
Pakistan
gave assurances including the rally
would be peaceful but Khan took to a
YouTube live address to make serious
allegations he said there was a plan
underway to Target him the former
cricket star turned leader has been
outspoken against the Pakistani
military's involvement in politics as
well as a traditional governing parties
I am warning all of you if I am
imprisoned or killed then you have to
stand and never accept it as a defeat
but you have to fight to the last ball
again I am telling you they're going to
eliminate me sooner or later so that
they can get rid of me and the movement
we started against these thieves who
have looted this country for decades
Khan also showed video of what he said
was his supporters being attacked by
police Khan's rallies and Court
appearances have been marred by violence
there have been confrontations between
his supporters and police but its
members of his party who say they are
the victims
look outside his house in the city of
Lahore members of the movement for
justice are convinced their presence is
needed to protect their leader
done the gates resemble the military
barricade but instead of soldiers it's
guarded by Khan supporters
we will eliminate the military that are
involved in politics if they think that
Imran Khan will be no more and will be
eliminated we will vote for the party
and this movement will continue it can't
be wiped out it's in the people's hearts
either Pakistan will progress or it will
be torn apart
Khan himself travels with high security
fearful of a possible attempt on his
life
members of the governing Coalition see
him as a disruptive Force within the
country
now he's making allegations about a plot
to assassinate him every day he's making
new claims and it's just a drama and so
far he's not presented any evidence as
night falls in Lahore more supporters
right here around Khan's house in
anticipation of another police raid many
here believe the ruling coalition
government wants to see Imran Khan and
his supporters go away quietly they are
caused by some to ban his party but so
far every move against Khan only seems
to increase his popularity Assad
Lahore Pakistan